[Music]
We went over
um the the rationale behind the tactical
architecture. Again, just in short, but
it's been said in the last video I
posted and it's been written out in a
reply in the uh text site. Okay. But in
short,
uh, for whatever reason, I ended up in
mid-range
grappling. So, all my other previous
tactical spectrums were
nonfunctional. In mid-range grappling,
you would attempt to do the throw
first. He ends up countering the throw,
but this is mid-range grappling through
internals. So, his center is being
seized and I am projecting
it. The wrestler, whoever it is who's
grappling with me, is going to realize,
they're going to feel
intuitively that the contact point that
I'm using is what is generating the
center seizure/p projection. So, they're
going to uh try to yin. They're going to
do a yin yield on that.
When they do that yin yield in that
moment, that arm is not connected to the
core muscle groups, it becomes very
manipulable. It will get them off that
center though. That's why they do it.
If you as a side note here when we do
the center projection or the koku
cultivation drill set it's very
important that the uk keep the same
energy and the same skeletal structure
so I can do that and as you are trying
to train your uk
or as we here we have lower level uk
just like they're anybody who doesn't
have enough hours in, enough reps, and
so they underperform. Okay? And one of
the ways that they underperform, the new
UK, the one who doesn't meet the
training equations yet, is when you try
the cultivation drill set and they go to
push, they do that. Or he goes to push
me back and they do that. And many of
you have been corrected. Hey, don't let
your UK do that. because we are using
their skeletal alignment to give us
enough gross insight into what we're
doing. Okay? But you saw in them in that
reaction the same thing that people do
at the speed of life inside a fight.
They're going to try to get rid of that
and regain control of their center of
gravity.
Okay, that is what is happening in
EQ. You seize their center. you're
starting to project it. They realize
they're going to lose their balance.
They're going to yiny yield or hyper
yiny yield on the arm. The arm is now
isolated from the core muscle groups. It
becomes manipulable and we do an arm
isolation technique. In this case, the
arm bar.
Okay, we went over that. We also noted
that uh we just don't have the
projection
skills either.
We we we can't generate the start of
that sequence because we cannot seize
the center andor we cannot project their
center such that it's their line of
gravity is going to fall outside their
base of support and so we cannot really
generate that arm isolation movement.
Okay. What that looks like is don't
don't project me just kind of do it
externally here is your uk is very
strong. the the the core is still able
to do what it needs to do here and even
push down. Your your federite uka
doesn't do that. They kind of are just
here and then they fall down. But your
your um ukas who are not trained in the
culture, they're able to wonder what
you're trying to do because they're
really strong here.
Okay. If you now try to push on them,
you that's where you get that walk.
Okay? For
example, we have to get that that
seizure and that projection. To do that,
we need internal skills. You just have
to go back to the co cultivation drill
set. You have to put in time. You have
to come here or you have to do the video
exchange. It takes years. There's no one
here who got it like it's some technique
to get. It's a skill to get. Skills take
years to develop. And uh you can see
here in our dashes here, while they are
ahead of where you all are at, they're
not all at the same level because they
have different levels of commitment and
they haven't all met the training
equations. But none of them uh have less
than one year trying to work on this
stuff. Okay? Many of them uh lots of
years working on it. And the ones who
are more skilled at it, they have more
actual training hours at it than ours
that are not as skilled at it.
Okay? So, you need to put your time in.
You need to be patient. Get in that
video exchange. Uh, and as I've shared
recently, Ivan is just proof it can be
done. I've never met him. We He's never
felt my technique, but he keeps he
exchanges the most videos with me out of
anybody in the group. So, just like the
Dashi here that can do it, they have the
most training hours out of the others
who cannot. Ivan has the most video
exchange hours out of anyone else in the
group. he can do it more than other
people can do it.
Okay. Uh the next thing that we have to
deal with is how not to push UK
away. And then the last thing to deal
with is how to do the X path.
Okay. So going in review again, we know
the rationale behind the tactical
architecture. I can't really generate it
until we address the second thing. I
need the internal skills. What do I have
to do? Not try to fix Eekio. Do the CoQ
cultivation drill set. This third thing
of not pushing UK away is we can fix
that. And if we fix this, we can kind of
game
ourselves to be able to also get the X
pattern. Okay? And that's what we're
going to do today. We're going to leave
the other two stuff off the table and
we're going to look at how do I not push
UK away. And by not pushing UK away, how
do I actually enter? Because I cannot
enter on someone who is perpetually
being pushed ahead of me because it's
impossible. Okay. All right.
So, the main thing is first let's set up
what we're looking at. We get to here.
Okay. You got to here. Um, and let's
mark his elbow in the vertical
plane. Okay. And we're going that
way. The push that I'm talking about is
I take his elbow and I continue to move
it in the direction that we're traveling
past where it
was. We'll do that one more time. Put it
right where it is. Cool. And now I push
it forward off that vertical plane
forward like that. That's the problem. I
can't enter on that because I am
perpetually moving them ahead of me.
Okay? And if I can't enter, then I can't
do the action
pattern. There's two places
uh well there's three places that allow
me to enter without pushing him forward.
The first one is related to the Koku
projection and his counter to the throw
in the hyper yin yield.
Okay. Um if he if he keeps his arm
straight then where I'm touching will
get his
center. So he hyperunials just like the
the bad training partner in the
cultivation drill set. Okay. But of
course that means that as I travel with
his elbow, he didn't go forward. Okay,
it's
yin. And this is very important because
this is now the harmonization of yin and
yang. He has yin. I can enter. When I
push the
elbow, his
inertia and his mass, his inertia
keeping him still is yong aspect. And so
this is technically a yongyong clash
when I push that ahead.
This is why, for example, you can do it
on smaller
uk or people you outrank because they'll
never go against you. Okay? and why you
can't on people that outrank you or
especially big heavy uk who outrank you,
right? Or big heavy uk who don't know
the choreography that they're supposed
to lay down. You you're feeling the yong
yong conflict. Okay? When you're trying
to rest someone or fight someone,
they're just going to resist it. You're
not going to be able to do it.
Okay? All right. So there is that first
yin yield when he hyper yin yields there
in response to the projection on his
center. We're not really going to play
with that
today. We're going to play with the
other two yin yields that I do. So when
I'm going to have him kind of push on
me. Okay. I don't go from the inward
spiral up to the elbow as many of you
are doing. So it kind of looks here I
here's my hand and you're going
here. This this grip here. I'll do it
slow. You'll see what's happening. Take
your hand off the mat. Okay. You'll see
that that elbow is moving forward. So
we'll do the plane
again. Okay. And me trying to go from
the grip to the elbow will make his
elbow move forward of the
plane. Sean, is she on the elbow plane?
I Yes. Yes. Okay. So, we'll do it slow.
I start to shift my weight. I start to
reach for the elbow and you start making
it go forward. At the speed of life, it
might only go forward an inch and you
got on the elbow. But you just made him
go forward. You made inertia go forward.
And it's just the beginning of that
pushing forward. Okay. What I do after I
get here is one more turn. So I get the
trap. And when I do that one more turn.
Are you there? Yeah. Okay. When I do
that one more turn, that's a yin yield.
You can see his elbows coming slightly
back towards me. Okay. We'll do it one
more time. I'm here like that. I do one
more turn. You can see that his arm's
coming back towards me. Okay, you
will how big you make it like any other
yin-yang reconciliation is dependent
upon
uh how much yang is in his grip. So, if
he has a lot of yong in that grip,
you're going to do a pretty big yin yo.
If he has, for example, very little yong
because in his projection, he barely has
any fingers on there. Do you see there's
barely any fingers? There'll be less
push as I come through. It's a very
small. Got it? Barely any fingers. Okay.
The wrist is going to do it. And not the
big hand movement. The wrist does it.
Boom. That's it. And I didn't push it
forward. If he has a lot of fingers on
there, that's when you that's a lot of
yawn. You're going to push it. So, you
have to you see how I brought the elbow
back towards me. Okay, that's the first
thing you have to do. And that should
have happened because you went for the
trap position first and
not this thing. You're you're over here.
Okay. So if the guy who yin yield what
they can always do is come back come
back in. Do you
see? So you can't assume with this cross
I reach all the way across and I'm going
to be fine because when he comes back in
I have my arm on the other
side. Instead I'm here like this with my
hands in front of my center. He comes
back in your hands are in front of your
center. You could do any number of
things. Okay? So you have to pass
through that
trap. That trap requires a new wheel
that makes him come back towards you
about an inch. Okay? Depends on how much
yawn he has. The next
thing is you have to understand why you
push the elbow in Fedride iikido. That's
the D pony
cue. like a a rider in D would do heel
pressure on the right leg. It tells the
pony, I want you to press. Okay. So,
same thing
here. When they push here, the UK knows
through
training, don't move that foot anymore.
Don't step with this leg. Go down on
that
knee. You see?
But you know as one of you found out
firsthand that there's nothing stopping
that UK from stepping with this leg as
you
push that one of you had that in your
video and we demonstrated that that
that's very possible. That's the
question no one asked in
Fedora. What is stopping the
UK? Why? What is making the UK leave
that foot there? Okay. There's nothing
there's nothing stopping them again.
Okay? So, you have to understand that
that was just a cue for them to do what
they've been trained to do. And you have
to understand that pinning cannot be
done with me pushing someone away from
me. Pinning is in and down, not out and
away. Okay? And I can't enter and
something that is being perpetually
moved ahead of me. So, if we get Mark
his
elbow, okay, you're going to notice that
his elbow does not go forward at that
line, but actually is coming this way on
the
line. So, we go here. Boom. There's that
little inch that I got there. and then
his elbows going this way on the
line. Depending on how much yawn he has,
how much inertia there was in the spinal
displacement,
uh you might not have it come this way.
It might just stay right where it's at.
Okay? But you definitely don't want to
shove it ahead of you. So, we have some
of your
submissions
where you're out here like that. Now,
that's not where your power is. Your
power is over here. We even had some of
our dashing that had that happen.
Okay. This is going around this
way. So, think about it in regards to
this. His elbow's out
there. I yield. My arm is out there. I
am going to
enter. But and you can see that this
elbow plane
please is still slightly forward of my
power line which is over
here. So if I push down on this straight
just go straight down.
You can see it's to my left where it
needed to be over
here. So there always was it's just
you're so used to the Federite way that
you move it that way that you you can't
see that there had to be some way that
on the one step he was able to bring the
UK's hand and his hand back underneath
him. Okay.
So,
boom. Start looking for that
elbow. Not going forward. Coming back.
Now that
said, you're going to run into the
problem. What's making him go
down? Because you lost your D skew. The
D cue was that he goes to his
knee. Okay, you lost
that. What's making him go down is the X
pattern.
That means his head is coming around
which it will because the elbow came
back. The inertia that was happening on
the spinal displacement when I bring the
head around makes the leg go around with
the centipal energy which you
experienced in the throw.
Okay. And
then you have the third force here at
the hip.
That's the
miashi. So that's where we're going.
Now, this
hip is going to be hit by this
koshi simply with the
edemi. It's nothing
more. Virginia, would you mind? You're
going to hold
this. Okay.
And you're going to when I say you're
going to turn his head by pulling it.
I'll push this to be the inertia. And
this is my cushioning. One, two,
three. That's all we're doing.
Okay.
Boom.
Boom. I am not having
therefore to push his elbow down.
He's falling. The elbow's going to come
down as gravity pulls his center of
gravity closer to the earth. Okay. I
just let it come back around me. I
push and I keep it on that trajectory of
the power line as we mentioned the
previous video. Okay. So, it's
effortless. Boom. Pop. make him fall and
aim him as he's
falling. When you have a
beginner, you kind of do it because he's
going to
fall. There's no there's no and you
know, I've said this many times in the
rest. My kids always laugh about how you
tell them how great they are at their
chem. They're they're just getting
thrown. I mean, they're good at keeping
their head off the mat, but they don't
have to do all the acrobatics that you
see all around, which, you
know, those people are. Those acrobatics
are impressive, but it's not iikido. My
people don't do that. They just get
thrown and they learn how not to die
when they hit the mat. There is talent
in that, okay? But it's not the
same as like Shiraava or those people
you know that have to know all this
choreography and be very gymnastic.
Okay.
So the
beginner doesn't need to know
anything for me to do this even slowly.
I just slow.
What if you mention my my beginners are
too afraid of it? Well, don't send them
flying. Just do the
geometry.
Boom. It looks pretty gentle. Okay. Um,
we're going to let everyone try this and
see if they have questions here and see
if we need to film another
clip. All right. So, when people see the
X
pattern, they will think of it through
the ego tripartite mind and they don't
understand the centripal energy is at
work. The centrifugal energy is at work
and the initial inertia of the spinal
displacement. It's these forces that are
at play and then it's a tiny
little bump. That's all it is. Okay. You
see the UK go flying boom, right? Boom.
Up high and you'll you'll go like I have
to do something big and it has to be uh
materialbased, matter based. It's not
matter based, it's energetic. Okay. Uh
those things have to be in place. So,
it's not uncommon when you now are able
to enter because you're not pushing them
away. You're now able to get into I like
to call this like a wave. So, I grew up
in Huntington Beach and we used to uh
shoot the tube all the time. And so,
there's a wave here. This hip is up
higher than the other hip. And that is
where my uh lead hip fits. Okay? And
then as I'm just entering, that's what
does the
displacement. Okay. You're now going to
not close the wave off because when you
when you push them, this hip is now
parallel to the other one and it's about
to get lower as you're going. The wave
closed on you. So like a new surfer,
you're like, "Dude, you missed the tube
because it it already closed on you."
Okay? There's a time and place for it,
and you have to be in the right time and
place with your arm. now coming back
towards you. It's going to probably be
there. You're going to return to your
material thinking and you're going to
try to trip this leg underneath where
you're doing something like that. I'm
not doing
that. Or you're going to do this over
rotate. I didn't do that either. Okay.
All I'm doing is fitting the yang koshi
into this yin spot that's here. It's
going in. Boom. Now, you have to
remember I don't do the federite
koshi. I don't I'm not in the stance
where this is not very long. It stays
yin. So, when we're
here, if you enter with that stance, you
don't get
it. Remember my admi enters on the
straight and then turns in. So you have
that foot slightly in and that's what
brings it. You don't have to go past
that. You don't need to do a hip bump or
anything like
that. That's different.
different enter as if you're doing idim
nag on this hand my style of idimi
nag that's
it you're fed
right they always freak
out they don't know what's happening and
because they feel So offbalance, it's
very common that they're going to try to
roll on
you.
Meaning you came out and you do a roll
that way. Okay? And they do something
like
that. You're going to do a
roll. Okay?
First, some of you already had that
experience, but it was exacerbated by
you were pushing the elbow as you were
trying to do the X
power.
Okay? You won't get as bad roll, but you
may feel their upward pressure as they
try to basically resist your technique.
That's what that is. They're not letting
you do
uh the technique. They're violating the
rule of neither assisting nor resisting.
Okay? So, all you got to do is keep
control of the
elbow constantly 90 fluctuation that
energy. You would feel it in your hand
because you had to fluctuate, but no one
else would know that they were trying to
roll out. Okay? That's the ideal. So, if
they roll out, it's not their fault. you
didn't 90 degree fluctuate that upward
lift into where you need them to go.
Okay. All right. Here I I told Sean and
Virginia to purposely try to roll out of
it. And we're going to watch
Ronin go ahead and 90 fluctuate.
[Music]
You can say he's not like umping their
their arms down. You can see the the
energy in them trying to do it, but it
doesn't change anything for the nag.
Okay, let's switch.
Nag and you're trying to roll out. Okay.
[Music]
And we got one cuz you push your elbow
forward and you push your elbow forward
on your demo, too.
[Music]
Come on. You see that little push
forward? You needed two moves to do it.
Caught it. Two moves again at the
end. Two moves
[Music]
again. Two moves again.
Carrie, you tried to muscle it. You're
too small to muscle
it. So, you have a straight arm and then
two moves at the end. Okay. Got got it.
So, again, we're not all at the same
level, right? Okay. Not even here in
this dojo. So it has an impact on what
we're able to work on and not work on
and what we should be working on. Okay?
Uh and so everyone is where they're at
and we just keep moving forward from
where everyone is at.